wendy williams shares a health update
with her fans amid her absence from the
wendy williams show we've got a lot to
talk about the 57 year old tv
personality posted a lengthy message to
instagram which kicked off with her
signature phrase
quote i miss you all as everyone knows
my health has been a hot topic i'm
making progress but it's just one of
those things that's taking longer than
we expected i'm a woman of a certain age
and i know enough to listen to my
doctors and will return to my purple
chair as soon as we all agree i'm ready
wendy went on to thank the staff and all
of the guest hosts who have stepped in
to fill her shoes while she's been out
which includes celebs like leah remini
whitney cummings sherry shepard and
michael rappaport i said what
what wendy also gave a shout out to the
stations who she says have been
understanding and supportive while she
recovers
and before she wrapped it all up she
gave a special thanks to her fans quote
i have heard your prayers and comments
and feel all the love you are everything
to me i love spending my mornings with
you all and i'm doing everything i can
to get back to work but right now wendy
has to focus on wendy no regrets wendy
who has been photographed in a
wheelchair as recently as last week has
yet to host an episode of season 13 of
the wendy williams show in september the
show revealed that she tested positive
for covid19 pushing the program's
september 20th season premiere date to
october 4th at that time wendy's brother
tommy williams jr shared an update on
her health during a live stream on his
youtube channel i did speak with wendy
she's she's stabilized she's doing all
right wendy's premiere was then
postponed again this time to october
18th with guest hosts filling in ever
since
after a couple of weeks back on the air
the show announced that wendy was still
struggling with health issues due to her
graves disease and thyroid condition my
thyroid my hyperthyroid is attached also
to graves disease i feel like they're
birds swimming around my head you know
like a cartoon
like
constantly high
but not high
at the time they posted a statement to
instagram revealing that while she was
quote making progress she was still
quote experiencing serious complications
the statement continued quote we want
her health to be her top priority as
soon as she's ready she will be back in
her treasured purple chair
i'm ready to go let's get started it's
time for hot topic
earlier this month the wendy williams
show announced that she will not be
returning to the talk show in november
upcoming hosts include bill bellamy
jerry springer and steve wilkos